jérôme marty médecin généraliste
président du sein du syndicat de l'union
française pour une médecine libre
bonsoir jérôme martin choix merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors on le voit
les choses s'accélèrent le gouvernement
qui prend des mesures pour éviter la
propagation de ce virus interdictions de
rassemblements de plus de cinq mille
personnes en milieu confiné même à
l'extérieur
si des personnes venaient des zones à
risque comment est ce qu'il faut
comprendre ces mesures elle s'adapte à
la situation la situation avance elle
progresse on va rentrer en phase
épidémique très probablement dans les
jours qui viennent on a un chiffre de
contamination qui est à peu près qui
doublent à peu près tous les deux jours
maintenant
donc il est probable que les mesures
prises vont se durcir un peu plus et
d'autres vont paradoxalement se relâcher
par exemple le confinement des
personnels soignants on voit bien que
déjà on ne parle plus que de confinement
pour les personnes soignantes qui sont
asymptomatiques et de mer il est
probable que on demandera aux personnels
soignants de travailler avec un masque y
compris ici il pousse aussi sont touchés
parce qu'on ne peut pas imaginer qu'on
retire du jeu
les personnels soignants au moment où on
va leur demander d'intervenir et les
personnels soignants sont ils à flux
tendu aujourd'hui
et sont ils ont ils suffisamment de
moyens pour faire face justement à une
épidémie une propagation éventuelle
la réponse est non la réponse est oui
pour le flux tendu non pour les moyens
en particulier pour la médecine de ville
je rappelle que le système français
etienne sur deux jambes une jambe qui
est la médecine de vie d'une femme qui
est l'hôpital et la médecine de ville
aujourd'hui n'a strictement aucun moyen
de protection on parle de masques qui
vont arriver dans l'est dans les
pharmacies la semaine prochaine ce sont
des masques chirurgicaux
c'est à dire ce sont des masques qui
sont donnés aux patients qui lui est
symptomatique pour éviter qu'ils
contaminent autour de lui mais le
médecin lui ne peut pas se protéger et
donc pour quelle raison parce qu'il n'a
pas de masques ffp2 qui ne sont pas
disponibles s'ils ne sont pas dans le
commerce aujourd'hui et il y en a pas en
stock on ne sait pas quand est-ce qu'ils
vont arriver et ça c'est gravissime quoi
alors je pèse mes mots mais c'est
gravissime pourquoi parce que le médecin
ne peut pas exercer dans de bonnes
conditions l'infirmière non plus on leur
demande de se protéger pour être sur la
brèche est resté auprès des patients et
là on ne sait pas si le patient en face
de nous et porter au nom de la maladie
puisque cette maladie assad particulier
qu'il ya pas mal de forme qui sont peu
symptomatiques voire non symptomatiques
donc ce que l'on demande du gouvernement
c'est d'accélérer accélérer accélérer
chose est de permettre aux médecins aux
infirmières à la médecine de ville jouer
pleinement son rôle qui est celle de
premier recours et deux premiers
remparts par rapport à cette maladie de
façon à justement éviter que les
urgences à l'hôpital symbolise avec tout
un tas de patientes qui vont aller
ensuite
et pourquoi justement ces personnels
soignants n'ont ils pas accès à ces
masques ils sont fabriqués à loin ben il
ya une demande qui est mondial
manifestement la france n'a pas su
prévoir les choses dans n'a pas mis en
réserve et aujourd'hui que la pandémie
arrive et que l'épidémie arrive on se
retrouve fort dépourvu en attente de
masques comme tous les pays du monde
dont quand est ce qu'on va être servi
ces masques concrètement ils sont
fabriqués ou cm alors il ya des
fabricants français puis a pris à des
fabricants chinois et les fabricants ben
voilà c'est c'est une demande qui est
mondial c'est un peu le problématique du
médicament vous savez que les pénuries
de médicaments en france parce que le
marché aujourd'hui et mondial qu'on
achète plutôt les médicaments moins
chers et donc on est servis en dernier
mais là pour les masquer on espère que
l'on ne sera pas servir en dernier
vous disiez l'épidémie verts restent
protégés fsk passé en face d'eux comme
on est en face de nous on est en face
d'eux des gens patients passent trois
ans pourquoi ça serait à la phase
d'épidémie
et alors que faut-il faire quelques est
ce que les citoyens doivent faire
justement pour se prémunir et pour
éviter d'être contaminé mais on est dans
une année au sein d'une crise sanitaire
qui est au milieu d'une autre crise
sanitaire puisque notre système de santé
va mal que ce soit l'hôpital les
urgences où la médecine de ville vient
se surajouter maintenant le convive 19
le gleut coronavirus donc ce qu'on
demande aux gens c'est d'avoir un
comportement extrêmement civique de
respecter toutes les consignes qui sont
données par le gouvernement et ensuite
d'aller consulter évidemment leur
médecin quand y lisons quand il rentre
de foyers épidémiques qu'ils appellent
le samu qui n'a y pas consulté leur
médecin
qu'ils restent confinés chez eux et
qu'il respecte ses consignes de
confinement quand on les leur donne
mais voilà c'est ensuite pour la vie de
tous les jours qu'il se lave les mains
régulièrement qu'ils respectent les
consignes de santé publique et que
chacun en fasse pas sa tête
c'est un rôle qui est aujourd'hui il ya
un rôle individuel qui est aussi
importante que le rôle collective et
vous disiez que certains n'ont même pas
de symptômes donc quand on se porte bien
comment est ce qu'on peut
être cynique comme vous le dites si les
symptômes n'apparaissent pas au bout de
combien de jours d'ailleurs à part et
ses symptômes mais on sait que la durée
d'incubation est de 14 jours
donc certains jeunes de 0 à 14 ans la de
0 à 14 ans gros seins
le propre d'une maladie infectieuse
c'est d'être invisible donc on ne sait
que la maladie aujourd'hui hélas il faut
pas tomber non plus dans l'irrationnel
et je rappelle que la grippe saisonnière
fait jusqu'à 10000 morts en france
chaque année c'est des millions de
jeunes touchés et qu'elle se transmet de
la même façon que cette pathologie
or il ne viendrait pas à l'idée des gens
de se mettre mastre la journée par
rapport à la grippe et il n'y a que 30 %
des gens qui se battent side et
aujourd'hui on voit des gens qui
s'affolent alors qu'il ya deux morts et
en gros 100 200 personnes qui sont qui
sont contaminés donc il va falloir quand
même raison de garder ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas se protéger il faut
respecter encore une fois les consignes
tout notre rôle est tout le rôle de la
population c'est de ralentir la
progression de cette maladie
le gouvernement dit que ça ne sert à
rien de fermer des villes comme ça a été
le cas en italie
vous êtes d'accord avec ça bien sûr dans
l'oise par exemple qui est un foyer où
il ya beaucoup de cas la sorte il faut
il faut agir au nom et pour l'instant on
est encore en phase où on agit sur ce
qu'on appelle les plus terre c'est à
dire les zones où il y a des gens
infectés où on va en quelque sorte
confiner ces hommes essayer de retrouver
tous les gens qui ont été en contact
avec les gens affectés de façon à
bloquer complètement la propagation de
la pathologie mais ça vraiment c'est un
s'est ainsi presque mission impossible
de trouver le patient zéro le fameux
passion 0 qui a été à l'origine de ces
contaminations mais le patient zéro
souvent il est guéri
de fait une fois que la pathologie
évoluer les mails et les pathologies
virales la plupart du temps les risques
seul donc la personne est guéri ce qu'il
faut c'est retrouver tous les jeunes qui
ont été contact et qui seraient
potentiellement encore contaminantes
pour éviter que ça continue à diffuser
et ça c'est compliqué ces eaux là on a
toutes les armes pour le faire
par contre juste je fais un aparté
rapide sur ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai la double
casquette fait cet aparté très
simplement parce que cette réforme on le
sait est dangereuse pour les personnels
soignants et notamment les soignants
libéraux au moment où on leur demande
d'être sur la brèche au moment où leur
demande d'être présent et où ils vont
remplir leur mission parce que c'est
leur rôle et leurs responsabilités en
leur plantant un couteau dans le dos en
imposant une réforme qui va mettre avant
leur profession et qui va baisser votre
activité
ce qui fait que moins en pour deux
personnes seront demain infirmières
médecins etc
je crois que ce gouvernement n'a pas su
peser le danger parce qu'ils viennent de
faire
et le mélange des genres peut être vous
a doublement mis en colère le fait que
oui on prenne pour en otage entre entre
guillemets bien sûr un secours au navire
russe pour faire passer à 49 3 ils ont
pensé quoi je crois qui est un poème
d'honneur un moment on pouvait très bien
aujourd'hui alors même qu'on est face à
une double crise sanitaire on pouvait
lire on ne suspend les discussions sur
les retraites les reprendra ensuite à la
place de ça on passe en force au mépris
au mépris notamment des soignants
libéraux puisque les députés sont aussi
dans un milieu confiné et ne sont pas
en tout cas d'être potentiellement
contaminées par ce virus donc suspension
pas possible donc puisque le 49-3 a été
brandie merci beaucoup jérôme marty
d'avoir remercier nos questions sur rt
france